hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar smarter sample preparation for
single cell sequencing I am Matt Ashton
of lab roots and I'll be your moderator
for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by miltoni biotech to learn more visit
miltenibiotech.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click Send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speaker
Karina and Marie product manager for
sample preparation at milteni biotech
Karina you may now begin your
presentation
hi everyone thank you for tuning in
today we have a lot of material to cover
so let's just dive right into it
so first we'll start out today with a
brief introduction to multinium biotech
and then we'll take a really deep dive
into tissue dissociation message so
we'll look at standard messages and then
modifications of tissue dissociation
message that have really been tailored
towards single cell sequencing and
really uh preserving that in vivaldene
expression pattern then we'll look at
nuclei isolation methods which has also
really increased in popularity lately
and we'll also look at some of the
differences between cellular composition
you might get between cells and nuclei
and then finally I'll summarize
everything and give some useful tips
miltoni biotech was founded over 30
years ago by Stefan milteni based on his
invention of Max technology which
enables the fast and gentle magnetic
separation of specific cells populations
based on their surface antigens early on
milpenney recognized the importance of
developing research products that avoid
so stress and maintaining the cell's
native functional Stakes or in other
words we understand that good research
Starks was happy cells
today multani biotech has grown into a
global company with a wide variety of
products to support anything from basic
research to selling gene therapy our
comprehensive portfolio includes
solutions for sample preparation cell
isolation cell culture flow cytometry
and advanced microscopy so a pretty
broad portfolio however today's talk
will really focus on our solution for
sample preparation
when you work with solid tissue there
are a number of steps to complete before
you have a single cell or nuclei
suspension ready for single cell
sequencing you might need to store your
tissue prior to processing then you need
to dissociate your tissue into a single
cell or a nucleus suspension and Then
followed by that you need to clean up
your suspension to remove debris and egg
cells as an optional step you can
isolate target cells via magnetic cell
separation or multi-parameter Excel
sorting finally the last step prior to
proceeding with your Downstream assay is
the QC of your cell or nuclei
suspensions to ensure sample quality and
the correct concentration
I wish we had time to go over all of
these steps today because they're all
important but I will mainly be focusing
on tissue dissociation so to learn more
about the other steps we have a really
great web page to focus on our solutions
for preparing cells and nuclei for
genomic applications that I highly
encourage you to check out
the food Association is the process of
transforming solid tissue into a single
cell suspension for our purposes today
I'm also going to call it dissociation
if you're transforming solid tissue into
a single nucleus suspension all of these
methods traditionally involve manual
mechanical processing and for cell
dissociation it may or may not include
enzymatic digestion so for example you
might use a stick blender to process
your sample so that might be
semi-automated or some people use bead
beaders to dissociate their tissue
samples I do not recommend that that is
far too harsh on your cells if you have
particularly soft tissue like spleen you
might be able to get away with just
mushing it through a cell strainer and
probably the most common method that
people use when you're doing manual
dissociation is they'll just take
scissors or razor blade and just chop up
the tissue into little pieces simple as
that so all these messings work but
multani uses something a little
different
thinks 2008 milteni biotech has offered
genomex technology as an automated
solution for tissue dissociation
gentlemax technology takes advantage of
simultaneous mechanical disruption in
enzymatic digestion to give the most
gentle dissociation possible
mild mechanical shearing disrupts the
tissue and increases the surface of the
tissue so that enzymatic incubation time
can be reduced to a minimum
in addition enzymes reduce the need for
strong mechanical forces because they
soften the tissue by digesting The
extracellular Matrix and the adhesion
molecules
so dissociating tissue and preparing
your Excel suspension without
introducing bias is a really critical
step for any single cell sequencing
experiment but it's a really tough
undertaking especially when isolating
cells from complex tissues such as brain
kidney or lung
ideally when you're making a single cell
suspension your goals are to have a high
viability cell suspension free of debris
or cell Aggregates likewise if you're
working with nuclei you want it free of
debrising cell Aggregates but instead of
high liability you're looking for nice
intact nuclei and then here's the hard
part you also want to make sure you're
maintaining the in Vivo expression
profiles of your cells as well as
maintaining the in Vivo cellular
composition
um so while tissue dissociation methods
have been around for a long time it's
really only been in the last several
years that there has been an invested
interest and ability to understand and
document the impacts of tissue
dissociation on gene expression which of
course is the result
um of the rising popularity of single
cell sequencing
the graph on the left shows the
tremendous grossing the number of
Publications with single cell sequencing
experiments while the graph on the right
shows the total number of cells analyzed
this explosion of single cell sequencing
data on a wide variety of tissues and
organs over a very short period of time
have left some to question how
Faithfully this data represents the
cellular compositions in gene expression
profiles of tissue in Vivo the first
Publications to explore this question
came in 2017 when this technology was
just starting to take off
in an early single cell rna-seq
experiment of dissociated and
fact-sorted muscle stem cells the
authors discovered that a subset of
cells Express high levels of
stress-associated immediate early gings
including Foss
they performed single molecule RNA fixed
to demonstrate that immediate early gene
expression is an artifact of
dissociation
in another paper published the same year
it was shown that stresses Associated
immediate early genes such as phosphi in
June were significantly upregulating in
kidney when a traditional warm
dissociation protocol was compared to a
cold dissociation protocol where the
cells were maintained below six degrees
to theoretically freeze the in-vival
gene expression profile
these Publications provided clear
evidence for what many researchers had
long suspected which is that
dissociating tissue and thereby removing
cells from their native microenvironment
will cause gene expression alterations
in some cell populations
so now the question becomes what are the
implications of dissociation-induced
gene expression alterations and what do
we do about it
this question was tackled in a really
great review paper by Machado at all
where they summarize what we know about
the impact of dissociation induced gene
expression artifacts and single cell
sequencing experiments as well as
emerging methods to mitigate these
alterations
one of the things they did that I really
liked is that they point out that not
all types of experiments are impacted
equally by dissociation induced gene
expression artifacts
for example it is least impactful in
experiments that compare cells at the
same state but different conditions the
assumption is that the dissociation
induced artifact is equivalent between
conditions and will be canceled out
next it could have an impact when
examining cellular heterogeneity such as
building a cell Atlas will go into some
of the differences in acquiring
different cell type compositions from
different methods later on and rare cell
populations may be lost based on your
dissociation method and while these
atlases are typically built with the
goal of documenting healthy tissue in a
resting state dissociation-induced
artifacts could confound that
finally the experiments most impacted
would be those comparing cells at
different transition points in a dynamic
process for example experiments eggs
interrogating activation of quiescent
muscle stem cells in response to injury
would be very impacted by this and the
officers even go into examples of how it
did impact their research
in a short time span a variety of
messages have been proposed to tackle
the issue of dissociation-induced
artifacts and Machado at all makes this
really nice summary table starting from
the right side of the table
bioinformatic message are frequently
proposed to correct sample preparation
artifacts and some Studies have removed
cells expressing high stress signatures
while other Studies have completely
removed panels of stress-related gings
from their analysis and others have
implicated even more complex algorithms
so these post-talk data correction
messages come at the risk of masking
real biological variability and
generally should be used as a last
resort
next is spatial transcriptomics which
has a men's potential and really
deserves its own um presentation but
we're not going to cover that today it's
still really in an early stage and is
not widely and easily accessible to all
next is RNA tagging such as trapseek and
this method enables studying cell type
specific RNA without the need for
dissociation or cell isolation however
this method requires sophisticated
transgenic animal models
so I'm going to spend most of my time
covering the these last four messages
and one method that I'm very excited
about is fixation
um so methanol has been used for a while
and because it's compatible with most
single cell sequencing chemistries
however it's been used with variable
success and one thing to know is that
most investigators are typically fixing
cell suspensions in methanol not tissue
so obviously that does not do anything
to prevent dissociation artifacts really
the biggest weakness of tissue fixation
with PFA was that until very recently it
was not compatible with most single cell
sequencing chemistries or 10x genomics
however that changed
very recently text genomics launched
their chromium fixed RNA profiling kit
which is compatible with formaldehyde
fixed human tissue what makes this
product especially powerful is that it's
compatible with fixed tissue rather than
just fixed cell suspensions this
facilitates tissue preservation at the
clinical site and is a really simple and
effective way to lock in your cell
Stakes as they worrying the intact
tissue
along with the kit 10x released a
demonstrated protocol for dissociating
fixed tissue using the general Max octo
dissociator they even reported promising
results using this kit with ffpe tissue
that was Associated using miltoni's ffpe
tissue dissociation kit
so this is all very new and multani
biotech has not had the chance to
develop a validated fixed tissue
dissociation protocol but we are working
on it
um so I'm really excited to see how the
scientific Community takes advantage of
this technological advancement
um but for now we'll have to move on to
more established messages
cold tissue digestion is an established
method and that it was initially
published on five years ago so a long
time for single cell sequencing methods
the transcriptional Machinery is largely
inactive at low temperatures which slows
down the dissociation induced gene
expression alterations and the enzyme
most commonly used for cold digestion is
a cold active protease derived from
bacillus lichen forms which has a
history of use in an industrial
applications and in laundry detergent
you can also use standard
um digestion enzymes at four degree but
of course they're going to be less
effective a big benefit of cold
digestion is that you end up with viable
cells that can be used for any other
method like cell sorting uh downside of
cold digestion is that during scriptural
changes maybe like cold shock response
are still possible
um and the biggest problem I see was
called digestion is just simply protocol
development just uh you can't just take
a warm dissociation protocol perform it
at four degrees and expect the same cell
yields so why don't we take a look at an
example of dissociating the same tissue
at 37 degree and four degree take a look
at the two different protocols and the
results
this was a very thorough messings paper
that came out of a group from Australia
and it looked at the effects of a
variety of different sample prep message
for single cell sequencing
um so the figure shows all the messages
they tested but right now we're just
going to look at their comparison of
warm versus cold dissociation
first let's take a look at the
dissociation protocols so for warmed
Association they use the multani biotech
multi-tissued Association kit to with
our genomex octo dissociator it's a 45
minute protocol to prepare the tissue
for that protocol you simply cut the
fresh kidney into quarters and then you
filter wash and filter or then what they
did was they filtered wash and filtered
again
um so compare that to the cold
dissociation protocol where first they
had to mince the fresh Mouse kidneys on
Ice into a smooth paste and then they
transferred that kidney paste into the
gentlemax C tube which also works on
dissociator with their own enzymatic
solution containing the cold active
protease
um then they had to combine turration
with the run on the gentlemax in the
cold room and so they did this back and
forth and that lasted about 40 minutes
and again they filtered washed and
filtered again
um so both of these protocols ended up
taking about the same amount of time but
one required the cold dissociation
obviously required significantly more
mechanical disruption in order to get a
single cell suspension
um the offers did not comment on total
cell yielding the publication between
these two different protocols but in um
miltoni's experience effective enzymes
are a really important part of attaining
good yield and from it's really
unfortunate that a lot of people don't
publish their cell yields when they
publish messages
um but typically with cold dissociation
um I think it's fair to expect a lower
cell yield than you would get with
swarmed dissociation
however a longer protocol and
potentially lower cell yields may be a
fair trade-off to prevent Association
induced artifacts the officers examined
the signature of 17 stress response
Kings and found that expression was
higher in cells that like through warm
dissociation compared to cold
dissociation they also observe that the
stress response varied by cell type
which was quite interesting some some of
the cells showed a significant
upregulation of stress Kings during
warmed Association while other cell
types showed no stress response
another promising method to prevent
dissociation-induced artifacts is to add
Inhibitors to the digestion mixture that
will stop transcription or translation
actinomycin D has been demonstrated to
be effective in several studies a
benefit of using Inhibitors is that it
maintains cell viability and is easy to
integrate into existing dissociation
methods the main disadvantage is that
this is still a relatively new method
and more studies are needed to explore
off-target effects and the impact of not
inhibiting all mechanisms of gene
expression alterations such as Gene
repression and post transcriptional
modifications
microglia are a good cell model for
dissociation induced artifacts because
they're highly reactive to their local
micro environment microglia are the
resident immune cells of the brain and
microglia activation has been implicated
in aging and disease so examining
microglial cell Stakes is of great
research interest
so here's another thorough method paper
that look that looks at a number of
dissociation conditions for adult Mouse
brain they perform single cell rna-seq
on facts sorted microblia that they
obtained through either warm
dissociation with multinibiotex adult
brain dissociation kit used on the
general Max octo dissociator or a cold
dissociation protocol that relied on a
down homogenizer without the use of
enzymes
uh and both messags were tested with and
without the addition of transcriptional
and translational inhibitors
the authors were motivated to find an
enzymatic protocol with minimal X of
evil transcriptional alterations
um in order to obtain higher yields uh
particularly when working with adult
Mouse spring
enzymatic digestion without Inhibitors
resulted in a significant cluster of
microglia that the officers designated
as X Vivo activated microglia they did
additional analysis to demonstrate that
the activation was mainly occurring
during the dissociation step
so the activated microglia were
characterized by increased expression of
immediate early Jinx and importantly
they showed that the cluster of
x-vivo-activated microglia was
eliminated when Inhibitors were included
in the enzymatic digestion which shows
great promise for this method
finally let's take a close look at using
single nucleus rna-seq as a substitute
for single cell rna-seq single nucleus
rna-seq has gained significant
popularity because it is the only method
compatible with slash Frozen tissue in
large cell types isolating nuclei is
also very fast and can be performed on
Ice which makes it ideal for single cell
sequencing
the main downside of using nuclei is
that you lose all the cytoplasmic RNA
and the cell surface markers that are
typically used for cell sorting
investigators new to single cell
sequencing are often concerned that
their analysis will suffer from
analyzing nuclear rather than whole cell
RNA but several Studies have shown that
you can detect similar number of genes
and transcripts and get comparable
information from nuclei if intronic rigs
are included in your analysis
depending on your starting material and
your desired analysis you may not always
have a choice to use either cells or
nuclei
so for example clearly feature barcoding
of cell surface markers will not be
compatible with nuclei and nuclei are
also not recommended for PCR or BCR
sequencing or analyzing RNA splice
variants
on the other hand nuclei are required
when performing attack seek or when
using the 10x multi-ohm kit
your starting material may also limit
whether you're able to use cells or
nuclei for example if you have flash
Frozen tissue then your only option is
to sequence the nuclei since it's not
possible to obtain viable cells from
flash Frozen tissue
or if you're interested in analyzing
very large or fragile cells that do not
survive the dissociation process or
perhaps they're too large for the
microfluidics of your single cell
sequencing platform then nuclei are the
best option
one drawback of using nuclei is that
they are very difficult to isolate
specific types of nuclei so if you're
working with a transgenic animal model
expressing a fluorescent marker in your
cell type of interest is possible if not
you have to rely on immunolabling to
enrich nuclei and it's very difficult
well Tenny biotech offers a great
solution for automated nuclei extraction
on the xenomax Octo dissociator it
combines gentle detergent-based cell
lysis with mechanical disaggregation
provided by the Sea tube which is
controlled by the instrument the whole
protocol is performed cold and later
this year we'll be releasing cooling
units to go with the general Max octo to
further simplify this workflow
here are the steps of our nuclei
isolation workflow you can start with up
to 200 milligrams of tissue and then
drop either fresh or frozen tissue into
a c tube with chilled nuclei extraction
buffer the C tube is enclosed and placed
onto the genomax instrument where tissue
lysis and homogenation is completed in
only five minutes moreover up to eight
samples can be processed in parallel
then the nuclei suspension is washed and
filtered and optionally further clean by
sorting on the max Quant title cell
sorter prior to single nucleus
sequencing
nuclei suspension from different tissues
will have different needs for cleanup
for example the image on the left shows
a nuclei suspension from Mouse liver and
it is already mostly debris free with
suggest a filtration step
alternatively the image on the right
shows the nuclei suspension from adult
Mouse brain and it still has a
considerable amount of debris even after
filtering Twice first through a 100
Micron strainer than through a 30 Micron
screener the nuclei from the adult Mouse
brain would need further cleaning to
remove debris before being used for
single nucleus sequencing
to demonstrate the impact of cleaning
nuclei suspensions we took two frozen
lung adenocarcinoma samples through our
nuclei extraction workflow and then
perform 10x single nuclei rna-seq on the
nuclei suspensions both before and after
sorting on the max Quant title we also
used flow cytometry to quantify the
level of debris both before and after
sorting we sorted on 7aad staining which
is a DNA binding die to separate the
nuclei from debris you can see here
sample one was quite dirty only nine
percent of the events detected were
nuclei before sorting after sorting on
the title the percent nuclei increased
to 40 percent but more importantly you
can see we had a very considerable
impact on Library complexity after
sorting the number of umis per cell
nearly doubled and the number of genes
per cell increased by 50 percent
sample 2 was much cleaner it started
largely debris free which is why the
post sorting Improvement in library
complexity is not as dramatic the
stemming streak set not all samples can
be treated equally especially when
dealing with heterogeneous human tumored
samples
here are the resulting clusters from
this experiment we were able to identify
cellular heterogeneitying the samples
and were able to find the major cell
types based on the expression of a
number of established markers
one thing to consider When selecting a
dissociation method for your single cell
sequencing experiment is that different
messings will likely yield different
proportions of cells this is especially
true when comparing cells to nuclei
a few papers have compared single cell
to single nuclei sequencing of the same
tissue and came to the same conclusions
demonstrated here while the same cell
types were recovered with both message
proportions were very different
immune cells tend to be more prevalent
in cell preps whereas parental cells
tend to be more prevalent in nuclei prep
in this example T cells which are shown
in Black made up around half of the cell
prep and about 15 percent of the nuclei
prep
conversely epithelial cells which are
shown in Orange made up about 15 percent
of the cell prep and about half of the
nuclei prep
the authors noted that while most
protocols varying cell recovery it's not
clear which if any provides a full
ground truth of cellular composition
however others have tried to answer this
question
let's take a moment to revisit this
paper where they looked at every method
the authors analyze cell type
composition for single cell and single
nucleus rna-seq as well as bulk RNA seek
from their own experiment in another
publication for the bulk RNA seek cell
type composition was inferred based off
the abundance of cell type-specific
transcripts
so the cell frequencies between messicks
were not drastically different
um they didn't analyze immune cells in
this graph however there is not a clear
pattern pointing to the accuracy of one
method over another
let's look at neurons from adult mouth
screen as one final example of the
differences in cell proportions between
cell and nuclei preps in this experiment
that we performed in-house Mouse brain
was dissociated with the genomax octode
associator with heaters and the adult
brain dissociation kit the cell
suspension was then filtered with a 70
Micron strainer and red blood cells were
lysed and debris was removed with the
debris removal solution finally we used
Max technology and our adult neuron
isolation kit to isolate the neurons we
then analyzed both the isolated neurons
as well as the bulk unseparated cell
suspension both with slow cytometry and
with 10x gene expression profiling
by both single cell rna-seq and flow
analysis we found that only about five
percent of the cells from adult mouth
brain were neurons
in the Single Cell RNA data we were able
to identify a number of diverse cell
types including microglia astrocytics
oligodendrocytes vascular cells epidemic
cells and peripheral mean cells we did
find two small neuronal populations in
the cluster graph you can see them
circled in red and to further
investigate the type of viable neurons
that we were able to isolate with the
adult brain dissociation kit we then
performed a second experiment where we
first isolated the neurons
after isolation neurons were enriched to
over 90 percent in the cluster graph
again all neuronal populations are
circled in red because we're able to
analyze significantly more neurons in
this Library we were able to detect more
neuronal heterogeneity we identified 11
neuronal subpopulations which consisted
largely of immature neurons
as you can see while we are able to
isolate viable neurons from adult brain
we were not able to see the full
neuronal diversity in adult brain
because many neurons are too large and
fragile to survive the dissociation
process
this is why most researchers opt to
isolate nuclei and perform single
nucleus rna-seq when investigating
neurons
we also tested our nuclei isolation
workflow by doing single nucleus rna-seq
on Frozen adult Mouse brain using the
10x gene expression profiling kit nuclei
from adult brain tissue has a
considerable amount of debris so we also
needed to use a Max Quant title
microfluid Excel sorter to clear the
nuclei from the debris
on the left you see an image of the
unsorted nuclei from adult Mouse brain
we also analyze these nuclei by flow
cytometry and found that only seven
percent of the events detected were
nuclei meaning there are positive for
7aad
that means that the vast majority of the
particles in that suspension were debris
rather than nuclei
after sorting the nucleon to the max
Quant Tito debris is no longer visible
and flow analysis determined that 90 of
the events were in fact nuclei
when we analyze the sorted nuclei
suspensions from adult mouth spring we
saw a considerable cellular diversity
detecting 34 clusters xenom as shown by
the graph on the left the two graphs on
the right show the cells expressing a
marker for either neurons or for a
neural cell precursor
this stemming streaks at nuclei prep for
able to detect a significant amount of
neuronal diversity whereas neuronal
diversity was limited when we used a
cell prep
okay that completes all the messages
that I have time to discuss today but
before we wrap up let's summarize what
we learned and then I'll leave you with
some practical advice
every method has its own strengths and
weaknesses so hopefully I've gotten that
point across today
um there's never going to be one perfect
method that does everything you want it
to so sometimes you have to make tough
decisions
so let's say speed was really important
to you if that's the case in extracting
nuclei is a clear winner
though if your nuclei suspension needs
clean up this might change the situation
if you are working with very small
amounts of tissue then cell yield will
be a big concern for you in this case
you should try either nuclei isolation
or warm enzymatic dissociation first
let's say you're doing a large
multi-center study then protocol
standardization may be important to you
in this case your best bet would be to
go with an automated kidding solution
such as genomax technology so we
currently have validated protocols for
nuclei isolation and warm dissociation
so preservation of in Vivo gene
expression is important to everybody I
know but it might be particularly
important to you if you are
investigating pathologies of Cell
Activation
all four are good choices but
um both by flash freezing intact tissue
or putting intact tissue into fixative
you have the ability to lock in your
Excel State prior to dissociation so
those two would probably be the best
options
you may need to enrich for or deplete a
specific cell type from your sample
prior to sequencing and this is easily
done with viable cells
finally the resulting cell type
compositioning can vary between
dissociation methods especially between
cells and nuclei
single nucleus sequencing is better
suited for very large or fragile cells
whereas if you're really interested in
cells with low RNA content such as
immune cells they might get
underrepresented by single nucleus RNA
sequin things so then you might want to
go with cells
for fixed tissue more study is needed
but early results show compositioning
similar to warm cell dissociation
so I came up with some general rules uh
tips practical advice for if you are
just getting into single cell or single
nuclear sequencing and are starting to
develop your own sample prep message
preparation of target cells or nuclei is
really the most critical step for a
successful single cell sequencing
experiment those experiments are
expensive so optimize your sample prep
message first and that will save you
time and money and sequencing in the end
and of course if you can practice
definitely practice I know people have
issues with very precious tissue but
especially if you're working with mice
um you have the tissue practice before
you start your experiment
consider using flow cytometry as a QC
method
um it's fast and provides a wealth of
information I just always like putting
this in here because I have a genomics
background and I wasn't exposed to flow
until I started at milpenny and there it
really is fast and there's a lot of
information there so if you are more of
a molecular person not used to the sell
side but now you have to start
dissociating tissue and working with
cells to do single cell sequencing if
you have access to flow cytometry I
definitely recommend it
um so every dissociation method will
have its own strengths and weaknesses
try to be aware of them and then choose
widely based on your tissue type
experimental needs and cell types of
Interest
and then of course one dissociation
method may not work well for every cell
type in a tissue just be prepared that
you might need Different Stroke that you
might need different dissociation
strategies if you want to analyze all
cells in the same tissue
so I used a lot of literature references
today I just wanted to lay them out here
for your convenience and I also added a
couple that were some good message
focused papers that has good information
in it but I did not have enough time to
get to today
thank you all for your attention today
I'll now be taking questions and if
you're watching this webinar um later on
on demand you could always email me a
question I've left my email up on the
screen there and if anyone would like a
copy of the slides feel free to email me
as well I'll send along a PDF copy so
thanks again and I look forward to your
questions
foreign
thank you Karina for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
okay let's get started our first
question is
is the gentle Max compatible with cold
dissociation
uh yes so I actually showed an example
of some researchers who did use the
general Max octo dissociator in a cold
room for cold dissociation so that seems
to be the most popular way to do it just
sticks the whole instrument in a cold
room
um I will mention that we don't have a
validated dissociation kit or protocol
for cold dissociation yet
um it is something we're looking into so
it would be something that you'd have to
figure out on your own but the gentlemax
instruments can be operated in a cold
room and we will be releasing cooling
Unix soon so you don't need a cold room
to do the cold dissociation if you
wanted to figure out how to do that on
your own and of course the nuclei
extraction needs to be performed cold so
that's what the cold unit cooling units
would be initially released for
okay thank you question two how should I
count nuclei
yeah this seems like a really easy
obvious answer but it's not um I think a
lot of people struggle with counting
nuclei because they uh use what they're
used to which is trypan blue
um on like maybe an automated cell
counter and nuclei with tripium blue on
your typical automatic cell counter just
do not work really well so obviously all
the nuclei are going to stain blue but
all your debris is going to stain blue
and you tend to not get very accurate
counts
um so we really recommend using a
fluorescent dye to count your nuclei
something that will bind the DNA and
light up so you get really good
differentiation between what's nuclei
and Lux debris and you'll get a much
more accurate count that way so
fluorescent dyes can be like pretty much
anything you want 10x genomics does
recommend 7aad if you're going to go to
do a downstream like a taxi Cafe and so
um some of the dyes that bind to the DNA
they found issues with
um if you're just doing an RNA assay
then any DNA binding dye should be
compatible such as uh Pi dappy
um aipo
whatever you have around
okay thank you
looks like we got a couple more
questions here for you uh question three
can I get a copy of the slides uh yes of
course so
um you can to get a copy of the slides
I'll send everyone a long Swan a PDF
copy
um you can just email me so my email
address is up on the screen right now
um and I'll send those along
okay thank you looks like
we do have time for just one more
question here Karina
um questions for well is will will the
military dissociations kits work with
transcriptional inhibitors
so this is not something we have tested
internally
um but we've seen now several
Publications where people are adding
transcriptional Inhibitors to our enzyme
digestion mix
um for the um dissociation step which is
typically performed at 37 degrees and
have found that to help prevent um
dissociation induce Gene and active
activation
um so all I I so I can't say anything
from miltoni because we haven't had a
chance to validate it internally but it
does seem like some people are having
success adding transcriptional
Inhibitors to the dissociation mixture
and it doesn't uh from what I can gather
it doesn't seem to be uh inhibiting the
diso the efficiency of the dissociation
people are still getting uh the yield of
cells that they're satisfied with
um yeah I think it's really yeah I think
it's really interesting but I I was yeah
we're working on it internally so
hopefully we'll have more to say later
okay okay great uh looks like we just
got one leg question
um here for you and then and then we can
wrap it up
can we isolate nuclei from Whole blood
so from Whole blood I would recommend
first removing the red blood cells
um so there's we do have a lot of
products for working with whole blood so
the first thing you want to do is just
Lysol the red blood cells because that
would obviously getting the way
um after you lice the red blood cells
and you are left with either your pbmcs
or your Buffy coat yes it's super easy
to isolate nuclei from your white blood
cells
um so you don't need the general math
for that they are pretty easy to lice
you get um you can use our nuclei
extraction buffer
um just sitting incubating in the lysis
buffer on ice is probably enough to lice
the pbmcs because they're fairly easy to
life
okay
well thank you Karina do you have any
final comments for our audience before
we go
uh yeah so when I recorded this uh
webinar 10x had not yet released a
protocol for ffpe on their uh fixed RNA
um profiling kit however they have
recently released that protocol and it
does use the milteni sspe tissued
association kit Upstream uh to
dissociate the sspe tissue so
um this kind of just recently got
released into the wild so to say so um
we're still waiting to hear back from
how it's working in you know the hands
of everybody's researchers but it's
pretty exciting
um so you know keep following us and
hopefully we'll have more news for you
about how that's working out but it does
seem to be a fairly simple workflow uh
use our kit to dissociate the ffpe
tissue you do follow the 10x protocol
there is one one-step key step
difference luckily that difference
actually makes a protocol like about an
hour shorter so that's nice
um and if anyone has any questions about
that you could of course uh contact
miltenny or 10x
great uh thank you again Karina for your
time today and your important research
we'd also like to thank lab roots and
our sponsor miltoni biotech for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
Roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time goodbye